شكرا لاحمد مشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا ميسون
عزام واحييكم ونستمر في هذه التغطيه على
مدار الساعه للاوضاع في السودان طبعا
اليوم الرابع على التوالي الانظار تتجه
الان الى ما ستؤول اليه الامور في الساعات
المقبله بعدما اعلن شمس الدين كباشي عضو
المجلس السيادي السوداني اعلن في مقابله
مع العربيه موافقه الجيش على هدنه مؤقته
اكدها ايضا يوسف عزت وهو المستشار السياسي
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع في تصريحاته
للعربيه قبل قليل
اذا مشاهدينا في التفاصيل قال عضو مجلس
السياده الانتقالي السوداني شمس الدين
كباشي في تصريحات للعربيه قال ان موافقه
الجيش جاءت بشرط ضمان التزام قوات الدعم
السريع بها وعبر عن اسف مجلس السياده من
التصعيد الحاصل وفشل التهدئه في البلاد
مشيرا الى ان الجيش كان مضطرا لدخول
المعركه نافيا قبول اي وساطه قال انها قد
تعرق للتصدي لمواصفهم بالمتمردين كباشي
قال ايضا ان الجيش سيعيد الامور الى
نصابها في اسرع وقت مؤكدا الالتزام
بالحفاظ على ارواح المدنيين
من المنظمه الامميه وايضا باتصالات من
الدول شقيقه
الامريكي
بوقف اطلاق النار لمده 24
نحن وافقنا على ذلك لمده 24 ساعه فقط
نظرا للظروف الانسانيه القاسيه التي
يعيشها مواطنا الخرطوم التحركات اصبحت
صعبه المستشفيات والخدمات في الكهرباء
والمياه نحتاج لهذه ال 24
لسماح للمواطنين بالحركه
والجهات الحكوميه المسؤوله بتامين
الاحتياجات اللازمه
اضافه ايضا للعربيه انها ما تقوم به قوات
الدعم السريعه يعتبر تمردا عسكريا واضحا
وفقا للقانون العسكري دعونا نتابع
القوات المسلحه كانت مضطره لدخول هذه
المعركه وهي في تصريح واضح جدا من الفريق
الاول محمد حمدان حميدي
بانه يعمل على اعتقال السيد الفريق اول
البرهان وتسليمه للعداله فهذا مستغرب يعني
هو لازال يعرف نفسه بنائب رئيس مجلس
السياده ويريد ان يعتقد رئيسه ويسلمه
للعداله هذه
واحده من القاعده العام تتبع للقوات
المسلحه بحكم القانون
وتعتمر بامره اذن هذا تمرد واضح
وبيوفق القانون العسكري ان هذا التمرد
في المقابل اكد يوسف عزت وهو المستشار
السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد
قوات الدعم السريعه اكد في مقابله مع
العربيه ان قوات الدعم السريع لا تعترض
على الهدنه
وستتصرف بمسؤوليه كامله تجاهها
نحن لغنا علمنا ذلك فيما يخص الهدنه من
البارحه اتفقنا مع السيد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي هو الذي اخترع هذه الهدنه وبعد
الدول الصغيره وافقنا واعطيناه الموافقه
كامله على ان يستجيب الطرف الاخر للهدنه
وهي الهدنه انسانيه
نحن من الساعه الثامنه بالامس تم توجيه كل
القوات في المواقع المختلفه قوات الدعم
السريع ان تلتزم بالهدنه وانت تحافظ على
المغارات التي تسيطر عليها ولا تتحرك اي
تحرك هجومي او
ان تسهل عبور المدنيين عبر الكبائر التي
نسيطر عليها هذا هذا كان توجيه واضح من
قياده الدعم السريع بالامس واعلن ذلك
اليوم في تغريده قبل خروج الكباشي او
كلامي في نفس الوقت نحن الساعه الثالثه
صباحا نتعرض لهجوم في القياده العامه التي
نسيطر عليها
وكان قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو قد قال ان الموافقه على الهدنه جاءت
لي ضمان المرور الامن للمدنيين واجلاء
الجرحى تربيه تلبيه لدعوه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
قال في تغريده له انه ينتظر المزيد من
المناقشات مع بلينكن حول معالجه مواصفه
بالانتهاكات التي ارتكبها الجيش السوداني
بحسب تصريحاته
وايضا قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان وقف
اطلاق النار مهم لاهداف انسانيه بالانقال
ان هذه الهدنه يمكن ان تشكل اساسا للعوده
الى المفاوضات نتابع
لقد اجيت اتصالا هذا الصباح بكل من قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والفريق محمد
دقلو حمدتي ودعوتهما لوقف اطلاق النار
لمده 24 ساعه فان وقف اطلاق النار من شانه
ان يشكل اساسا لعوده المفاوضات نتواصل مع
نظرائنا من الامارات والسعوديه وبريطانيا
بشان السودان لقد تعرضت قافله دبلوماسيه
امريكيه امس لاطلاق نار في السودان لكن
جميع الافراد بخير وهذا التصرف طائش وغير
مسؤول
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنا من مدينه مروي ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي اهلا بك نزار
اخر المعلومات المتوفره لديك وكيف هي
الاجواء الان قبل ساعات قليله من ما نتمنى
ان تكون هدنه ستطبق بين الطرفين
كنا نستمع الى ذوي المدفعيه
المستقبل سلاح المدفعيه التابعه للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه هذه القبائل كانت تنطلق
مباشره نحو مطار مروي الدولي تحديدا الثقه
التي تتمركز فيها مجموعات وقوات الدعم
السريع قبل قليل هنالك مصادر للجيش
السوداني اكدت ان هنالك مجموعات مقدره
وكبيره من قبل قوات الدعم السريعه التي
كانت قد تمركزت داخل
محيط ومركز مطار وقاعده مروي الجويه قد
خرجت من المطار واتجهت جنوبا جنوب محليه
مروي
سالنا هل هو انسحاب كامل هل بات المطار
الان بكامله والقاعده بكاملها في سيطره
الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه
اكدوا بان الامور تمضي نحو ذلك لكن لم
يصدر بيان رسمي يوضح حقيقه الامر ويعلن
بصوره مؤكده بان المطار بعد الان تحت
سيطره الجيش السوداني بس سؤال نزار فيما
يتعلق بما ذكرته من انسحاب هذه المجموعات
الى جنوب محل مروي او محليه مروي هل هناك
من ممر امن لمن يريد الانسحاب ام ماذا
طريق بري يربط بين منطقه مروي والمناطق
الجنوبيه هنالك شريط ممتد من القرى وهنالك
طريق ايضا بري فرعي يربط بين مدينتي عبره
بولايه نهر النيل وبين مدينه
ايضا طريق بري مفتوح يربط بين منطقه مروي
ومحليه دونجل في الجانب الشمالي من هذه
الولايه الممرات سالكه
التي نقلها لنا شهود عيان قبل قليل قالوا
بانهم شاهدوا ارتالا وسيارات
لقوات الدعم الفريق الثاني للجنوب دون ان
تكون هنالك ملاحقه لقوات الدعم لقوات
الدعم السريع من قبل القوات المسلحه
السودانيه لا ندري ايضا هل ستتم ملاحقه
هذه المجموعات هل يرتكز الجيش في احدى
النقاط خلال هذا الطريق كل هذه المعلومات
الان غائبه وربما حسب ايضا بيانات ومصادر
الجيش قال بانه سيتعامل وفقه معطيات الارض
والميدان لحسم هذا الوجود بقوات الدعم
السريع بمحليه نبوي من حيث تتمركز قوات
الدعم السريع في ان كان محيط او اطراف
المطار من اين تحصل على الامدادات
قبل قليل كانت هنالك تصريحات لعضو مجلس
السياده
القائد بالجيش السوداني الشمس الدين كباش
الفريق اول ركن شمس الدين كباشي ذكر وكشف
عن المعلومات المتعلقه بوصول مساعدات
عسكريه عبر طائرتين يوم امس من جهات لم
يسميها قد تكون ايضا حسب ما نفهمه حسب
القراءات والمعلومات بان هذه الطائرات قد
مدت القوات التي كانت تحيط بالمطار هذا
يفسر من اين تاتي هذه الدعومات لكن حتى
قوات الدعم السريع لم تعلن من اين تتحصل
فقط المعلومات المتاحه ما ذكره عضو القائد
للجيش السوداني الفرقه والركن الشمس الدين
طيب ابقى معنا لانه الان وصلتنا هذه الصور
التي كنا الان نتحدث عنها عن انسحابات
لمجموعات تابعه للدعم السريع من مطار مروي
كنت تتحدث عن سيارات وايضا اليات خرجت دون
ملاحقتها في طريق باتجاه جنوب محليه مروي
وهذه هي صور الاوليه التي تاتينا لهذا
الخروج الخروج لهذه الجماعات وان كان ليس
لدينا معلومات عن طبيعه هذا الخروج ان كان
يعتبر انسحاب تسليم ام ماده خاصه وان هذه
المجموعات خرجت دون ملاحقه من قبل القوات
المسلحه واعود للحديث اليك نزار حول هذا
الانسحاب هل لدينا ارقام عن من هم في
الداخل حجم القوات المتواجده
والباقيه داخل
المطار وفي نواحيه وبالمقابل عن حجم من
انسحبوا نتحدث عن مجموعات يبدو انها ليست
بالقليله
نعم ليست بالقليل قوات الدعم السريع عندما
وصلت الى هذه النقطه قبل اسبوع من الان
كانت في حدود ال 100 سياره وصلت اليها
مجموعات اضافيه من المناطق مختلفه لا ندري
العدد الكلي لهذه القوات امس الاول القوات
التي انسحبت قوات الدعم السريه من خارج او
من داخل هذه القاعده الجويه في المروي
كانت تقدر بنحو 50 الى 40 سياره خرجت تبقت
مجموعه من القوات هي المجموعات التي يبدو
انها انسحبت اليوم
العمليات ما زالت مستمره عمليات القصف
المتكرر من قبل المدفعيه ما زالت مستمره
وان كنا نستمع اليها في بعض الاحيان وتسكت
بعض الاحيان في حاله الصمت وهدوء يراقب من
قبل المواطنين في مدينه ملوي العمليه
مستمره هذا مؤكد
معطيات وقراءات الميدان غير واضحه لانها
مستمره عمليات التمشيط عمليات الاحاطه
وعمليات التمركز مستمره من قبل القوات
المسلحه السودانيه
فرديه ان يتم استخدام الطيران العسكري
حاضره وبقوه خاصه وانما فعلا كانت هنالك
مغارتان جويتان طلعتان جويتان حلقتا عبر
الطائره الحربيه في سماء مدينه مروي وقامت
بقصف بعض المواقع والارتكازات لقوات الدعم
السريع داخل المطار الدولي هذا المكان
الجيش اعلن بالسابق بانه يسيطر على
الاجواء وهذا يضع علامه استفهام كيف
استطاعت طائرتان امداد الدعم السريعه عود
الى هذه النقطه ولكن دعني اتحدث عن هذه
الصور التي نشاهدها لمشاهدينا هذه الصور
اوليه جاءتنا الان لما يقال بانه خروج
لجماعات باعداد كبيره طبعا من الدعم
السريع من مطار مروي ولكن دون اي مواجهه
وهذا يدفعنا للتساؤل نزار ان كان لدينا
معلومات ان كان هناك نوع من قناه الاتصال
ما بين الجانبين كيف يمكن لمثل هذا الخروج
ان يتم بسلام بهذه الطريقه ان لم يكن هناك
نوع من الاتصال والتواصل
حسب ايضا
قاله عضو مجلس السياده القائد للجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه الفريق اول ركن
شمس الدين كباشي للعربيه قبل قليل بان
التفاوض وان التفاهم الان غير متاح وغير
موجود وهم يسعون كما قال
لحسم الامر على ارض الواقع وارض المعركه
التقديرات كثيره تقديرات ميدانيه لغرفه
العمليات هنا في مدينه مروي التي تدير هذه
المعركه العسكريه هنالك تكتيكات كثيره
تستخدم في مثل هذه المواجهات
سطح الممرات اخذ طريقه او وضعيه فتح مسار
للانسحاب كان الجيش مسبقا قد ذكر في
البيانات بان كل من يريد ان يسلم نفسه
وينسحب ويلقي بالسلاح من قبل قوات الدعم
السريه فان الجيش موافق على هذه الخطوه لا
ندري حتى الان بصوره عمليه ومؤكده الطريقه
التي خرجت بها القوات الدعم السريعا
وانسحاب هل هو اعاده تمركز وانتشار ان كان
في كلا الفرضيه في كلا الطريقتين سيبدو
انه ايضا حسب معلومات العربيه لان الجيش
الان يسعى لوضع خطه وتصور واضح لكيفيه
التعامل مع المرحله المقبله من هذه
العمليه العسكريه التي دخلت في يومها
الرابع وتمضي نحو اليوم الخامس ونعود الى
النقطه التي اشرت اليها فيما يتعلق
للطائرتين كان في اعلان سابق في بدايه هذه
الاحداث من قبل الجيش السوداني تتحدث عن
ان الجيش يسيطر على الاجواء هو
صاحب الطائرات اذا مصحه تعبير وبالتالي
السؤال هنا وصول مثل هاتين الطائرتين
لامداد الدعم العسكري ماذا تقول لنا او هل
من تصريحات اخرى رسميه تتعلق بهذا الاطار
لا تصريحات غير هذه التصريحات الرسميه
التي تصدر لاول مره من شخصيه قياديه
وقائديه عسكري في الجيش السوداني لكن
الاشاره التي وردت في الحديث الفريق اول
شمس الدين كباشي هي مهمه بان الطائرات او
بان الطائرتين وسلطه لم يهبط داخل مطار
مروي او في حدود محليه مروي وانما في
مناطق الشماليه حدوديه او في مناطق
الغربيه الشماليه للولايه الشماليه يعني
ان الطائرات وصلت الى تلك المناطق النائيه
ووصلت اليها السيارات التي اخذت هذا الدعم
العسكري هذا
يفهم ويفسر حسب ايضا القراءات العسكريين
عندما طرحنا هذا
قبل ان تصل هذه الطائرات الى نقاط قريبه
اكدوا بان الطائرات اذا ما وصلت ستصل الى
مناطق تكون بعيده كل البعد عن مسار ومسرح
العمليات الذي يوجد فقط في شمال السودان
داخل قاعده مروي الجويه ولكن هنا نسير
سؤال اخر كيف استطاعت هذه العربات الوصول
الى هذه الطائرات لتحميل ما تحمله هذه
الطائرات ونقله من مكان الى اخر وهذا
يدفعني للتساؤل عن الوضع بصوره عامه في
محيط المطار وايضا في مروي بصوره عامه
المنطقه الثرويه منطقه مفتوحه على اتجاهات
مختلفه على اتجاهات شماليه على اتجاهات
شرقيه على اتجاهات غربيه
المنطقه هنا التحرك فيها يتم في مساحات
واسعه ومساحات شاسعه
هذا يترك المساحه عسيره على
احاطت كل القنوات وكل المحاور بقوات
وباسلحه وباليات وبمدرعات لكن السؤال حول
كيف وصلت هذه القوات وكيف استطعت ان توصل
هذا المدد ربما للعسكريين اجابه اكثر مني
في مثل هذه الاوضاع وكيفيه القدره على
الحد من وصول المساعدات الى مناطق قريبه
يعني نحن نحاول ان ننقل منك ما يمكن ان
تستطيع الوصول اليه من معلومات في ظل وضع
الحالي او مشاهداتك على الاقل
ونقطه مهمه فيما يتعلق
بان لا تفاوض التي اشرت اليها خلال الحديث
عن ما ذكروا الكباشي للعربيه لا تفاوض
ولكن الدور الامريكي يبدو انه كان فاعل في
فرض رؤيته فيما يتعلق
بالهدنه التي وافق عليها
الطرفان وبالتالي السؤال الان بحسب
المراقبين بحسب ما يتناقله البعض هل هناك
من امال بانه هذه الهدنه ربما تكون بارقه
امل هل الدور الامريكي يمكن ان يتسع
ليصل الى نقطه يمكن القبول به كمفاوض بين
الاطراف الاخرى او لديها اوراق لفرضها
ماذا يقول المراقبون بهذا الاطار ردود
الفعل
المراقبون والقارئون لما الات الوضع
الامني والعسكري والسيادي في السودان هم
يرون ان الاختراق الذي حدث بقبول القوات
المسلحه لهذه الخدمه لمده 24 ساعه ختمت
بكلمه فقط هذا يعني ان بعد الهدنه هنالك
حديث وربما يكون حديث عسكري على ارض
الميدان ولكن قبول القوات المسلحه
السودانيه بهذه الهدنه ربما يعطي مؤشرا
ايضا حسب متابعين ومراقبين على ان الجيش
السوداني ايضا له تقديرات على ارض الواقع
له تقديراته
معايشه الظروف الانسانيه التي يمر بها
المدنيون يمر بها المواطنون في مدينه
الخرطوم الفرصه لاخذ الانفاس للمواطنين
الذين تقطعت بهم السبل لكن المؤكد ايضا هو
بحسب المراقبين المقربين من المشهد
العسكري بان الجيش سيواصل في هذه العمليه
العسكريه
الى نهايتها الى ان يضع حدا كما قال لكل
التفلتات التي حدثت من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع والحديث هنا لمراقبين ولقاده
عسكريين في الجيش السوداني
لحقوق الانسان يتحدث عن ان العنف اوقع 185
قتيل و1800 مصاب هل لدينا
تفصيل حول ان كان هؤلاء من المدنيين او او
النسب اذا ما صح التعبير ما بين المدنيين
والعسكريين او لازال الوضع ضبابه بعض
الشيء نزار
الوضع الضبابي
ومعقد ومتشارك هذه النسبه التي ذكرتها
الان هي تضم مدنيين وعسكريين هي تظل نسب
اوليه قابله للتحديد وقابله للارتفاع في
ظل عدم قدرته وصول الاطقم الطبيه
الهلال الاحمر
الصليب الاحمر والاطقم المساعده من
الممرضين ومن الاطباء لعديد المناطق سواء
كان في مدينه الخرطوم او في مدينه ام
درمان او في مدينه الخرطوم بحري او في
محطه النيل هذه هي المناطق التي تشهد
اشتباكات حاده وعنيفه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع نتوقع بحسب المعطيات على ارض
الواقع ان ترتفع هذه النسب طالما هنالك
ارتفاع للصوت الرصاص وطالما هنالك استخدام
للذخيره الحيه وللمدفعيه الثقيله
وللطائرات التي تدوب سماء الخرطوم هذه نسب
اوليه وهنالك دعوات من قبل الاطقم من قبل
المنظمات التي تعمل في المجال الانساني
والغوص الانساني بضروره ان يتم الانتباه
للوضع الانساني وان ياخذوا فرصتهم لمعاينه
ولمعالجه الاضرار التي لحقت بالمدنيين
جراء هذه الاعمال المستمره لمده خمسه ايام
من مدينه مروي مراسل العربيه نزار القداوي
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع قياده الجيش
بتوجيه ضربه عسكريه بالطيران الحربي
للدائره الطبيه لقوات الدعم السريع والتي
تقع داخل نطاق تواجد المدنيين بحي شباط
بمدينه بحري وقد استهدفت الضربه العسكريه
اسرى القوات المسلحه والمصابين من الطرفين
والمدنيين الذين يتلقون من مساعدات الطبيه
والانسانيه داخل مستشفى الدائره الطبيه
هذا واظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه حجم الدمار
الذي لحق بمطري الخرطوم ومروي وتعرض الصور
المشاهد لطائرات مدنيه وعسكريه مدمره
بالاضافه الى اللقطات لاعمده النيران
الناجمه عن الحرائق
وفي هذا الاطار دعونا نتعرف على ابرز
مطارات السودان والتي تدور فيها وايضا حول
هذه المطارات مع عارك بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع نتابع
اهميه استراتيجيه تحظى بها المطارات في اي
نزاع مسلح والوضع في السودان ليس استثناء
لهذه الاهميه في قلب الخرطوم يقع مطار
العاصمه وهو الاكبر في السودان انشئ
المطار عام
1947 ومر بعده عمليات توسعه واعاده تاهيل
حتى بات مركزا ل 95% من حركه الطيران
الخارجيه في الاشتباكات الحاليه في
السودان كان مطار الخرطوم محور رئيسيا
للاقتتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع خاصه وان المطار مدني وترتبط به
قاعده عسكريه جويه
اهميه اخرى يحظى بها مطار الابيض في
المدينه التي تحمل ذات الاسم على بعد 450
كيلومترا غرب الخرطوم فالمطار نقطه وصل
بين العاصمه ومعظم مناطق دارفور كما انه
مركز لقوات حفظ السلام الامميه في منطقه
ابياي المتنازع عليها بين السودان ودوله
جنوب السودان
اخيرا الى مطار مروي الواقع في الولايات
الشماليه وتتداخل فيه الاهميه الاقتصاديه
بالعسكريه هذا المطار كان من المشاريع
المصاحبه لانشاء خزان او سد مروي للاهميه
في الري وتوليد الكهرباء وكما هو الحال
بالنسبه لمطار الخرطوم يحتوي مطار مروي
بدوره على قاعده جويه
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا
بك لواء امين اسمح لي ان ابدا بقراءه
بالمشهد الان وردود الفعل عسكريا لماذا
تقبل اي جهه بهدنه ما
مساء الخير يا مرحب بك ومرحب بالساده
المشاهدين
اي هدنه يتم الاتصال عليها في بدايه
الصراع او وسط صراع او نهايه صراع بكون
عندها دلالات في حاله السودان الان في
بدايه الصراع واضح انه هناك حاجه لاخلاء
جرحى تقديم خدمات لمحطات المياه التي تم
الاعتداء عليها محطات الكهرباء ايضا اخلاء
بعض المواطنين الذين عالقين في مناطق
النزاع هذه الهدنه
بتتم وفقا لقواعد اشتباك ويبغى
لبروتوكولات دينا
عسكريه متفق عليها باعتبار انه هنالك
مدنيين لا علاقه لهم في هذا الصراع الجانب
الانساني تحرك دكتور امين الان من قبل
الطرفين يعني بعد اربع ايام
هنالك مناشدات طبعا واحساس من الطرفين
يبدو ان الطرفين احساء ان هنالك حالات
انسانيه تستحق الهدنه
وبالتالي هي شيء ايجابي وليس
لا نضعه في خانه انه تقصير او تاخير لكن
هذه هي الحروف وبالذات حروب المدن بيحصل
فيها بعض الاشكاليات الانسانيه
وانا اعتقد انه في مناسبات بين الامم
المتحده بدات امس الاول بهدنه اربعه ساعات
ورغم انه ما تم التزام بها بالدرجه كبيره
لكن كنا بنتحدث من شاشه الحدث انه بيكون
فيها شيء ايجابي انه يمكن تكراره يمكن ان
تتحول الى هدنه وهذه الهدنه الان يمكن ان
تتحول الى وافقه اطلاق النار طيب شيء جميل
بس انا حابه اقراها من الجانب العسكري
لواء امين خاصه انه الجيش كان يقول انه
الحديث عن هدنه هو الالتقاط الانفاس وهذا
ما يريد الدعم السريع بمعنى اخر انه
الدلالات عسكريه اكثر منها انسانيه
وطبعا هذا الحديث كان في اليوم الاول
واليوم الثاني والانفاس تتعالى والمواهب
على الارض ايضا متغيره ولكن
كل دقيقه حساباتها ولكل موقف حساباته
واعتقد انه الان بعد اربع ايام المعلومات
وصلت للقيادات للطرفين والاضرار وصلت
للطرفين فلا يمكن ان نتحكم بالخطاب الاول
ونحاسب لماذا لم تبادره الهدنه من اول يوم
هذه هي
المعارك تقوم بهذه الطريقه وهذه هي
المواقف متغيره يمكن ان يصدر رافت اليوم
بناء على مواقف معينه بناء على قدرات
معينه بناء على ضغوط وتدخلات خارجيه
النقطه الاساسيه اللي بدي احكي عنها فيما
يتعلق بالضغوط بعيدا عن المناشدات السابقه
الجانب الامريكي كان له مكالمه للطرفين
للرجلين وبالتالي تم الاعلان عن هذه ابقى
معي سيدي سانتقل لبعض
المعلومات التي وردتنا واعود اليك لانه لا
يزال التضارب في الانباء هو سيد الموقف
داخل في هذا الصراع طبعا بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع في اخر فصولها الجيش اكد
السيطره على الاوضاع في نياله بولايه جنوب
دروس دارفور عذرا في وقت تشهد في عاصمه
ولايه جنوب دارفور قتالا بين الجانبين
للسيطره على مطار المدينه نتابع واعود
اليك
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر هذا هو مغرهم الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
اليوم الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الخرطوم الدولي وهو الامر الذي ينفيه
الجيش نتابع
[تصفيق]
الان بمطار
الخرطوم المدني
قوات الدعم السريع ايضا نشرت فيديو لبعض
جنودها قالت انهم من داخل القياده العامه
في الخرطوم دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
البرهان القياده العامه
ابشر والله ابشر والله ابشر والله ابشر
الان داخل القياده العامه
عشان الناس ما تقول اشاعات وانه نحن ما
استلمنا القياده والشباب منتصرين باذن
الله واللي قدام ان شاء الله واللي قدام
ان شاء الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر عشان الناس ما تقول
اشاعات وان الدعم السريع واذا الان الدعم
السريع مسيطره على كل الاوضاع داخل
القياده
مبروك مبروك يا شباب مبروك مبروك مبروك
بعيدا عن صحه القتال تشتد حرب موازيه بين
قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
حربون لا تقل ضراوه يترشق فيها الطرفان
البيانات والبلاغات مستخدمين صورا واشرطه
فيديو الحديث هنا عن حرب المعلومات فمنذ
بدايه الاشتباكات في السودان لم تتوقف حمى
الاخبار والبيانات عن اجتياح وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي اخر فصول هذه الحرب
الصراع الدائر حول مبنى القصر الجمهوري
فبينما اكد مستشار قوات الدعم السريع يوسف
عزت سيطره عناصر الدعم على القصر الجمهوري
لم يتاخر الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني في
نفي ما وصفه ادعاءات قوات الدعم السريع
ونحن نسيطر على القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر
على كل
المتواجد على طول كل الوزارات نؤكد انه لا
صح اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميديشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مقرات القياده العامه
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر
الجمهوري هذه التعذيب فصل اخر من الحرب
الاعلاميه دار حول مبنى التلفزيون فطرفان
اعلن معنا السيطره على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في ام درمان الجيش السوداني
اكد استعاده السيطره على المبنى وبث بيانا
وصف فيه قوات الدعم السريع بالميليشيا
لتعود لاحقا قوه الدعم السريع وتبث صورا
امام مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون وتؤكد
سيطرتها بالكامل عليه امام الهيئه القوميه
ام درمان نحب نطمن الشعب السوداني انه
قواتكم قوات الدعم سريعه الفازله الان
مسيطره على اذاعه القوميه من هنا ام درمان
اذاعه جمهوريه السودان
حرب المعلومات امتدت الى حدود مقر اقامه
القائد الاعلى للجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
عناصر من الدعم السريع نشرت مقاطع فيديو
اكدت فيها اقتحام منزل البرهان قبل ان
ينفي مصدر في الجيش السوداني ما تم نشره
معتبرا ان الخبر مضلل وغير حقيقي
من بين اهم الادوات المستخدمه في حرب
المعلومات هذه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
التي تعرج بالكثير من الاخبار الداعمه
لروايه طرف على حساب اخر وان كانت هذه
الحرب النفسيه الموازيه لا تزهق ارواحا
الا ان تاثيرها قد يكون اكبر على مجريات
الاحداث وسام الذهبي العربيه
اعود اليك لواء امين للحديث عما يحدث كل
جهه تعلن انتصار تفنده الجهه الاخرى هل
نحن امام حرب اعلاميه ام انه الخارطه
العسكريه واضحه بالنسبه لنا من يسيطر على
ماذا
يعني تم تجهيز لها يبدو مبكره
ان ت لغت مطلقه الاولى
هنالك فيديوهات قديمه خاصه بالدعم السريع
الذي كان متواجدا في العصر الرئاسي منذ
عامين وكان متغيرا في حراسه التهيئه
الازاوه منذ عامين هذه اوضاع كانت موجوده
بموافقه الدوله حينها مثل هذه الفيديوهات
تحتاج الى تاكيد طبعا
واضح انه التلفزيون القومي الان اعاد بس
وهذا يعني تلفزيون الدوله
ومن ناحيه ميدانيه يعني
القاده العامه والمطار والقصر الجمهوري
راينا هذه الافلام منذ اول يوم في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي الان تبث في رابع يوم
باعتبار انه يستغلون على المطر نفس
المقاطع نفس الخلفيات
نفسي
استدارات الدخان بعد الاعتداء على
الطائرات
التي يتم
تعاطي معها فيما يتعلق بسيطره الدعم
السريع لواء ابقى معي
انتقل الان معي الان تنضم الي من القاهره
اسماء الحسين مدير التحرير صحيفه الاهرام
والمختصه ايضا في الشؤون الافريقيه اهلا
بك سيده اسماء اسمحيلي ان اتحدث عن دور
القاهره وطبعا استمعنا الى الرئيس المصري
يقول بانه مصر لن تتدخل ولكنها تتابع عن
كتب وخاصه في ظل وجود ليس فقط الجنود
المصريين الذين كانوا هناك في
دورات تدريبيه ومناورات ولكن ايضا للحديث
عن المصريين المتواجدين نتحدث عن الالاف
ومنهم الطلبه في السودان
اهلا وسهلا استاذه ميسون التحيه لك ولضيفك
الكريم والساده المشاهدين الكرام الوضع في
السودان هو وضع خطير ومعقد
والاتفاق على ان يكون هناك هدنه لمده يوم
هو بدايه طيبه من اجل وقف اطلاق النار
الذي تسعى له الان القاهره وعواصم اخرى في
الاقليم والعالم بشكل حسيس لانه ما يجري
ستكون تداعياته خطيره للغايه وقد بدانا
نرى اتهامات كل طرف للاخر بانه يسعى
للاستعانه باطراف اقليميه واذا ما اتسع عن
نطاق الحرب في السودان سيكون له تداعيات
خطيره على الاقليم قد يؤدي الى تشابك
الامر مع اطراف اخرى هذا ما تسعى القاهره
لكي لا يكون وهي نعم ذكرت انه هناك جهات
تلجا الى جهات اقليميه نحن نتحدث عن ما
اشيع من انه هناك
مساعدات قدمت للدعم السريع من خلال
دول بعينها ام ماذا
نعم يعني هناك اتهامات من كل طرف للاخر
وهذا يدق اجراس خطر بانه هذه
الادعاءات ان كانت ادعاءات او حقيقه يمكن
ان تتحول الى واقع اذا ما استمرت الحرب في
السودان وطال امد هذا الصراع
لا شك انه سيكون له تداعيات كبيره جدا على
الاقليم والسودان والمنطقه والقاره
الافريقيه كلها منطقه تقاطع مصالح اقليميه
هذه هي النقطه
سيده اسماء هذه هي النقطه الرئيسيه لانه
انا اريد الاشاره الى الدعم السريع قال لا
صحه للمعلومات التي تتحدث عن محاوله جهه
اقليميه انزال مساعدات عسكريه في مطار
مروي وبالتالي النقطه الرئيسيه انه لا احد
يعترف بذلك ولكن اذا ما فصلنا المشهد من
هي الاطراف المعنيه والتي يمكن لها ان
تتدخل ويكون لها مصلحه في الفوضى والتقاتل
داخل السودان
قد تنجر يعني هناك جهات بالفعلت الصراع
وفي داخل السودان نفسه وهناك امتدادات
سكانيه وبشريه للسودان نفسه في تمتد مع
دول جواره وقد تنحاز هذه حتى الامتدادات
السكانيه لهذا الطرف او زاك حتى ان لم
تنحاز الحكومات نفسها وبالتالي الوضع خطير
للغايه ولذا تسعى القاهره لكي تحاصر هذا
هذه النيران التي اشتعلت في السودان والتي
يعني ستكون امر خطير جدا واعلنت انها على
مسافه واحده من كل الاطراف وان كل ما تسعى
اليه هو وقف التصعيد الحالي واعاده
الاطراف الى مائده حوار يتم فيها حل
المشاكل بالطرق السلميه وبالطبع اعلنت
ايضا حرصها على سلامه جنودها وان كان هذا
الامر ايضا يتكافئ
يتوازن معه هو الحرص على سلامه السودان
نفسه وابنائها الجنود وايضا ابنائها من
المصريين المتواجدين في السودان سواء
كانوا طلبه او عمال او مقيمين في هذا
بالاضافه الى ملفات اخرى ان كنا نتحدث عن
الامن عن السد ايضا وهو ملف مهم بالنسبه
لمصر لكن اسمحي لي سيده اسماء ان انقل
لمشاهدينا هذه الصور ولكم ايضا التي
وردتنا الان الجيش السوداني يقول بانه
يسيطر وسيطر تامه على مقر القياده العامه
للجيش طبعا هذه الصور وصلتنا الان في ظل
تضارب المعلومات والمتعلقه بمن يسيطر على
مقر القياده العامه للجيش طبعا الدعم
السريع كانت قد قالت قواته بانها تسيطر
على القياده العامه للجيش والان نشاهد هذه
الصور التي
يبثها الجيش السوداني والتي يشير من
خلالها سيطر ته الكامله على مقر القياده
العامه للجيش اعود اليك سيده اسماء للحديث
عن الملفات العالقه
وتاثيرها على الجانب المصري واهميه هذا
الذي وصفتيه بمحاصره الوضع او حصار الوضع
من قبل مصر حتى لا يتطور ما طبيعه الدور
المصري المطلوب الان ان كنا نقول بانه لن
يتدخل مباشره
نعم مصر قالت واعلنت على لسان الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي انها ستعمل على الاتصال
بالطرفين المتحاربين والعمل لخفض التصعيد
وانها ستشارك في كل الجهود التي تسعى الان
لوقف اطلاق النار في السودان وبدات مصر
اتصالات واسعه جدا مع الامم المتحده مع
الاتحاد الافريقي مع دول شقيقه وصديقه دعت
الاجتماع طارق في الجامعه العربيه
بالمشاركه مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اتفقت مع جنوب السودان على ان يكون هناك
استعداد لوساطه اعتقد ان هناك حاجه الان
لتكثيف وتجميع وحشد كل الجهود الداعيه
لوقف التصعيد سواء كانت من دول مؤثره في
الاقليم او في العالم من اجل الضغط على
الطرفين والا يستغل هذه الهدنه التي تم
الاتفاق عليها من اجل اعاده التقاط
الانفاس وترتيب الام وانما تكون بدايه من
اجل حل حقيقي لا يسعى فيه طرف لسحق اخر
لانه الحل العسكري في السودان يعني لن يحل
الامور في السودان ولن يفكك ازمتها وكل
قضايا السودان المعقده العميقه تحتاج الى
حوار وتحتاج الى توافق واسع وليس ولن يكون
حلها ابدا عبر السلاح لانه هذه ورطه كبيره
دخل فيها الطرفين المتصارعين ودخل فيها
الشعب السوداني كله والمنطقه والعالم الان
يدرك حجم هذه الورطه ويسعى الى حل سلمي
للازمه لا يؤدي الى انفجار اوضاع كثيره
جدا على جبهات عديده تشارك السودان فيها
جيرانها والاقليم والعالم الولايات
المتحده تدخلت وتحدثت مع الرجلين والهدنه
ربما تكون
خرجت من رحم هذه الاتصالات ولكن قالت
الولايات المتحده وبليكن تحديدا باننا
واشنطن تقف على مسافه واحده ما بين
الرجلين هذا الموقف من الولايات المتحده
طبيعي مطلوب ام ماذا
اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده تعتبر ان
الطرفين يعني كانوا شركاء في العمليه
السياسيه وانها تسعى لحل لكن اعتقد انها
اوصلت رسائل قويه جدا للطرفين وقد تكون
هذه الرسائل هي رسائل تحذيريه لانه هناك
تصريحات لاعضاء في الكونجرس يلوحون فيها
بعقوبات على قائدي الجيش والدعم السريع
وايضا على القيادات العسكريه النافذه في
الطرفين اعتقد ان هناك تحذير قوي جدا وصل
من واشنطن الى الطرفين وهذا هو في حقيقه
الامر ما زحزح مواقفهما التي كانت تتمترس
بالامس
وثلاثه ايام الماضيه خلف مواقف متطرفه هو
هذا ما زحزح الامر وجعله ما ينصتان
للموقف الدولي والاقليمي الرافض لهذه
الحرب ويجب ان تتواصل وتتكثف الضغوط في
رايي لانه ليس بالنداءات والرجاءات والشكب
يمكن ان يستجيب الطرفان
لمطالب بوقف التصعيد والذهاب الى وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار والى اي حد هذه المواقف تؤثر
على العمليه على الارض والمواجهات
الموجوده سيده اسماء افقي معي انتقل
للدكتور امين اسماعيل لواء امين عندما
نتحدث عن موقف كدوله كبرى من الولايات
المتحده تقف لتقول بانها على مسافه واحده
من الطرفين هذا الموقف يساعد على الحل
لا ينعكس على الارض بشكل سلبي او ايجابي
هذا ما تحاول الولايات المتحده على
المستوى العسكري التاثير عليه
هذه بتقدير رساله تطمينيه باعتبار ان
الوسيط يجب ان يكون مقبول من الطرفين ولا
يمكن لوطيه دولي مثل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان يتحدث انه ينعاد الى طرف
لذلك هذه رساله تطمينيه تعلن على الميديا
باعتبار ان الولايات المتحده الان اصبحت
وسيط مغول اما
ما يدور في الغرف المغلقه او الاتصالات
المغلقه فهو الموقف الذي تريد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهو تقديم نموذج
ديموقراطي في افريقيا بعد ان فشلت في
العراق وابغانستان ولذلك هي تحاول لملمه
اطراف الازمه السياسيه في السودان وهذا
التصريح يساعد ويس الثقه لدى الطرفين
النومه مرغوبان الان وبالتالي هي رساله
تطوينيه وليست خطا برتقالي وليست
خطا سياسي الجيش كان واضح سنطبق الهدنه
سنقبل بهذه الهدنه ولكن لا تفاوض اعتبر
الجانب الاخر عمليه تمرد كامله وبالتالي
يجب انهاءها والنقطه هنا اذا كنا نقول ان
الولايات المتحده استطاعت ان تنجح في هذه
الهدنه هل ستستطيع ان تفرض نفسها كوسيط
ضمن مفاوضات بين الجانبين ايضا
المفاوضات تبدا طبعا بحسن النوايا واحده
من حسن النوايا
الهدنه الانسانيه
وطريقه اخر وايقاف الحملات الاعلاميه
والتصريحات والبيانات وبالتالي تكون
الخطوه
عن طريق مفروش الى التفاوض صحيح القياده
الجيش صرحت بانه لا تفاوض باعتبار ان هذه
قوه
عسكريه تمردت
وتم التعامل معه على هذا الازار وتمردت
ولم يقفوا عند ذلك على مستوى الداخل لكن
دكتور امين ايضا هناك مطالبات بادانه ايضا
هذا التمرد طبعا اسمح لي ان انقل تصريحات
لوزاره الخارجيه السودانيه في هذا الاطار
لان دعت المجتمع الدولي لادانه التمرد
تمرد قوات الدعم السريع على القوات
المسلحه ايضا بيان للخارجيه قال ان الجيش
هو المؤسسه الرسميه الشرعيه والمسؤول عن
استقرار والحفاظ على الامن الخارجيه
السودانيه دعت الامم المتحده لادانه قتال
الدعم السريع في المدن والمناطق السكنيه
والذي يعرض المدنيين والنساء والاطفال
للخطر طبعا من جانب اخر السفيره الامريكيه
لدى الامم المتحده ليندا غرين فيلد طالبت
الاطراف المتصارعه في السودان على وقف
اطلاق النار طبعا وذلك للسماح للعوده الى
المحادثات وانهاء النزاع دعونا نستمع الى
مقالته
نحث الاجهزه الامنيه على اتخاذ خطوات
فعاله للحد من التوتر وضمان سلامه جميع
المدنيين وموظفي الامم المتحده وغيرهم من
الدبلوماسيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني وقف اطلاق النار هو السبيل
الوحيد لحل القضايا العالقه وضمان وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه واستئناف المفاوضات
لوضع السودان على طريق اتفاق سياسي
ومع تاجيل الصراع بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع دعونا نتعرف على ابرز القاده
العسكريين من الجانبين
[موسيقى]
مزيد معنى من الخرطوم رئيس التحرير صحيفه
التغيير رشا عوض اهلا بك سيده رشا قبل ان
ابدا باي معلومات متوفر لديك بهمني اعرف
ردود الفعل واصداء قبول هذه الهدنه ان كان
على المستوى الشعبي او على المستوى
السياسي
هي تحيه للمشاهدين الكرام
ولضيوفك من القاهره والخرطوم
طبعا
الشعب السوداني الان ما فيه الذين
تندلع هذه الحرب
يتعطشون لاي مخرج امن يضعفشون لهذه الهدنه
لان هناك احتياجات انسانيه ملحه
تتطلب وقف القتال حتى يلتقط هؤلاء
الابرياء
انفاسه
ونتمنى فعلا من الطرفين الذين خذلوها يعني
مرارا وتكرارا ان يلتزموا بهذه الهضمان
اما اوضاع البدنيين
خطيره جدا عن اوضاع المدنيين كان في انباء
تتحدث من قبل الجيش في انتشار للدعم
السريع داخل المدن يعرضوا ليس فقط السكان
ولكن ايضا البعثات وغيرها النساء وغيره
والاطفال للخطر عن ماذا نتحدث هنا كيف هو
الوضع في الشارع
طبعا الدعم السريع ارى بياض وقال ان هذه
فنون
وزعت زي الدعم السريع على افراد منها
ومارسوا هذه
الاعمال
وان الدعم السريع ليست له علاقه بها طبعا
نحن حتى الان لا نملك التحقق من مصادر
مستقله ولكن المعركه التي تدور هي معركه
تكسير عظام بين الطرفين
على قراءه للموضوع انها هي حرب بين فصيل
انقلابي اسلامي يتخفى تحت مظله القوات
المسلحه في مواجهه الدعم السريع وهي ولذلك
كانت المعركه بهذه
الشرع الانقلاب انقلاب على الدعم السريع
ولا انقلاب على الدوله شكل الانقلاب الذي
تتحدثين عنه او على الاتفاق
نعم انقلاب
على المسار الانتقالي برمته لان الاسلام
ويين لا يعرفون سوى احتكار السلطه بشكل
مطلق ولا يعرفون سوى فرض وصايتهم على
الشعوب رغم ارادتها
وبحكم وجودهم وتغلغلولهم في مفاصل الدوله
حتى بالشراكه وهناك معلومات على الارض
تقول انهم طالعون في هذه الحرب بل هم من
اشعل
الان الاوضاع الميدانيه على الارض يبدو
انها احدث التغيير
في تفكير كثير من الاطراف الاقليميه
والاطراف الدوليه وعلى راسها مصر تحديدا
مصر كانت
تراهن على ان حكم عسكري في السودان
بالانسان وان هذا سيتم
خاطفه وسريعه تقضي على الدعم السريع وتجعل
الجيش
انت عم تحكي عن مؤامره هلا تتحدثين عن
مؤامره الان
مؤامره اتحدث عن معطيات
تابعناها طيله الاربع سنوات الماضيه طبعا
هي عندما يعجز
الاطراف في اداره الملفات الوطنيه
بمسؤوليه يفتح
هذا
المهم ان الدرس الذي نستخلصه مما يجري
الان كما قلنا مرارا وتكرارا
العسكري التقليدي الذي تتطلع اليه نصبه في
السودان يحتاج الى مؤسسه عسكريه واحده
بقياده واحده نحن الان امام الواقع
الملغوم الذي اورثنا له نظام الاسلام
وي وهو وجود عدد من الجيوش على راسها
الجيش الاصلي السوداني وفي موازاته الدعم
السريع الذي تضخم وتحول الى جيش كبير
شو هو السلام في السودان كان يقتضي تصميم
مخرج سلمي
ديمقراطي تخرج بموجبه كل المؤسسات
العسكريه مخصوص السياسيه وتقول السلطه
المدنيين وتجري عمليه شامله وجذريه
للاصلاح الامني والعسكري
فهدف الجيش
المهني
سلميه ولكن الاطراف التي لا تريد
الاستقرار للسودان رفعت الى هذه الحرف
تحسب انها ستكون خاطفه وسريعه ولكن على كل
مصر قالت بانها لم تتدخل ولم تتدخل في هذا
الموضوع بحسب تصريحات السيسي ولكن الخاسر
الاكبر بغض النظر عن ان كانت مؤامره كما
ذكرتي وتحدثتي او لا الخاسر الاكبر هو
الانسان دعونا نتحدث عن الاوضاع الانسانيه
لجنه اطباء طبعا السودان هذه اللجنه تحدثت
عن ارتفاع عدد القتلى من المدنيين جراء
الاشتباكات الى 144 شخص طبعا هناك معلومات
كانت تتحدث عن وصوله الى 100 واكثر من 80
شخص ونتحدث ايضا عن اصابات تصل الى 1400
اللجنه حذرت من حصيله القتلى من المدنيين
جراء المعارك الشرسه ولفتت الى صعوبه
اجلاء وحصر عدد القتلى وايضا المصابين
بالاضافه الى العالقين اللجنه قالت ان عدد
من المستشفيات توقفت عن تقديم خدماتها اثر
تعرضها للقصف اللجنه نشده طرفي النزاع
والصراع لفتح ممرات امنه لمعالجه المرضى
ومعالجه المصابين وايضا ايصال المخزونات
الغذائيه والطبيه لمستحقها
على كل المزيد معنا من الخرطوم الدكتور
عطيه عبد الله عطيه وهو سكرتير عام اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان المنتخبه
اهلا بك دكتور عطيه اعطينا اخر المعلومات
المتوفره لديك والوضع الصحي بصوره عامه في
السودان وكيف يمكن له ان يتجاوب مع ما
يحدث على الارض
شكرا لكم اجدد التعازي لجماهير الشعب
السوداني
وخالص الامنيات والصحه والعافيه لكل
الجرحى والمصابين وعودا حميدا لكل
المفقودين نعم ابتدي من ما رشح عن وقف
اطلاق النار او هدنه لمده 24 ساعه اتمنى
ان تكون هذه هدنه حقيقيه من مصادقه من كلا
الطرفين
بالامس وقبل ان جسم ميلاد البيانين يتجدد
اطلاق النار مجددا
نعم هنالك طواقين طبيه منذ صبيحه السبت
لما نتمكن من استبدالها او
ارسال مساعدات غذائيه او او طبيه الى هذه
المستشفيات عدد من المستشفيات خرج عن
الخدمه لهذه الظروف
نجدد صوتنا
وطلبنا المتكرر ايقاف هذه الحرب فورا وان
لم يحتكم طرفاء الصراع الى الى صوت العقل
نتمنى ان تكون هذه الهدنه بضمانات حتى
يمكن اجراء كثير من المرضى داخل
المستشفيات ايضا ايصال المساعدات الطبيه
واللوجستيه لهذه المستشفيات ارسال كوادر
طبيه
لاستبدال هو الكوادر هنالك
ما نكون سنكمل ربما الحديث عن الوضع
الانساني والطب تحديدا في نشراتنا اللاحقه
دكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه سكرتير عام
اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان
المنتخبه شكرا جزيلا لك اشكر ايضا من
الخرطوم كانت معنا رئيس التحرير صحيفه
التغيير رشا عوض ومن القاهره اسماء الحسين
وهي مديره تحرير صحيفه الاهرام والمختصه
في الشؤون الافريقيه شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا
وطبعا مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره على
العربيه بعد دقائق من الان يكون معنا خالد
والمزيد حول ما يحدث في السودان مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات